[Musica]
gli amici dell'infanzia si ricordano di
me perché grasso ma giocavo bene a
calcio avevo dribbling e allora penso
che non c'è niente di più bello se si
viene ricordati all'interno di un
contrasto
qualcuno di voi può dire
domanda la mia pancia mi ha salvato la
vita
perché io ho una volta
scavalcando mi sono infilzato un
cancello x 6 cm dentro la pancia
a detta del medico a pochi millimetri
dagli organi vitali
nonostante la ferita ho deciso di
proseguire il tour poetico che stavo
facendo con una sacca drenante nella
ferita aperta
a cambiare ogni 24 ore quindi diciamo
che il tour si chiamava finché non trovo
un lavoro tour ed è diventato anche un
tour nel tour di pronto soccorsi
italiani o impone in mente questa scena
di una dottoressa che
l'inter ha sulla maglia per controllare
questa ferita con la sacca mi guarda e
dice solo una parola
turpe
e così ho proseguito proseguito il mio
tour anche
internazionale perché sono andato la
sera stessa con questa sacchetta
drenante
a lugano dove c'era un po i tre slam non
so se sapete cos'è un poetry slam a una
gara tra poeti una gara di poesia e dove
il pubblico decide in maniera molto
divertente
il vincitore è un modo per trasmettere
portare la poesia in giro è estremamente
bello e ve lo consiglio frequentato i
poeti slam
della nostra regione
ma da quel tour è passato molto tempo
gran parte del quale trascorso in
reclusione in attesa di nuove idee e
ispirazioni
ma come fa un poeta a fare della propria
poesia un lavoro
addirittura vi togliessero il palco da
sotto i piedi
rimarrebbero solo i piedi
e allora ho preso a camminare mi dirigo
in val borbera sul confine tra piemonte
e liguria in un piccolo posticino di
nome ficino dove si trovava per lavoro e
per creare il suo nuovo album il mio
amico video un de stefanis in arte
nebbiolo musicista e cantautore ci vado
perché avevo preso molto peso nel
trovare l'ispirazione diciamo i muscoli
erano ridotti a poco è la motivazione
aveva bisogno della sua amicizia leale
l'idea era quella di rimettermi in forma
e andare in giro assieme organizzando un
nuovo tour e raggiungere i posti dove
avremmo suonato le canzoni e letto le
poesie a piedi
pochi mesi dopo le biolo però ci lascia
a 29 anni praticamente all'improvviso
l'ultima volta che l'ho visto era per il
suo compleanno sembrati a festeggiarlo
io
il mio peso mi hanno fatto una storta
alla caviglia e avevo una stampella e
lui aveva le stampelle perché non poteva
camminare con quei medicinali
e ci siamo scambiati qui c'è stato
questo gesto di scambiarsi la stampella
perché
lui aveva due diverse quindi gli ho dato
la mia così come gesto nel ricordo bene
insomma quindi è il progetto di
camminare resto solo con una persona
seduta nel cuore che non mi faceva più
dormire io il più grande poeta italiano
a livello di metri quadri
leggermente fuori allenamento compirò
una sfida non da poco camminare da
torino a venezia
520 chilometri una media di 25
chilometri al giorno con uno zaino
sbagliato da 16 kg 150 kg di peso
corporeo in partenza
due occhi in più oltre ai miei grazie a
chi nel tempo ha amato nebbiolo amici
parenti ascoltatori nasce il progetto
the walking point un grande funding live
che a pochi giorni dalla partenza
raggiunge già il budget per creare una
borsa di studio destinata a giovani
cantautori under 30 il premio nebbiolo e
inoltre un video animato del suo primo
singolo inedito del nuovo album a cui
aveva lavorato senza poterlo suonare in
un palco e con un pubblico per
concludere questo breve intervento
rileggo una poesia io e nebbiolo
condividevamo la stranezza tra le tante
del chiamarci io mi chiamo burban che di
cognome lui guide di nome e per questo
vorrei leggergli una poesia che piaceva
molto a lui e che leggevo durante le
nostre serate assieme dedicata a chi non
ha mollato pur avendo un nome inconsueto
come noi dandoci coraggio sto parlando
del maestro il più grande violinista
italiana nel mondo
uto ughi
questa è ad autumnia
come dire il bene e il male ugo al
plurale ughi a ballare lui ughi mentre
il ritmo e celestiale uto ughi sta
suonando e scende il maestrale cambia il
tempo ho dovuto perché sei caduto in un
imbuto ughi siete anche voi perché chi
di noi non si è sentito avuto almeno una
volta ughi tutti i giorni aiuto voluto
non voluto per volontà del padre della
madre uto ughi yoghi e bubu fusi come un
sayan con un violino in mano un naso
adulto ughi non ti ho mai conosciuti non
vi abbiamo mai conosciuto ughi eppure mi
è sempre parso di averti accanto
suonando sparuto ugis partito uto
partito che vorrei votare ughi e allora
uto ughi come dire faccio cose usi e
costumi dell'essere umano muto e
disumano e braccia rubate
all'agricoltura
urio souto ughi corpo legnoso geppetto
dell'anima avuto un maestro ciliegio
palissandro avete ma schiato a cielo
abete rosso però è vano bosso ughi il
boss aiuto proibito il più grosso di
tutti lutero nonio il sughero chi
passami il sughero che sta più in tuo
onore questo vino interiore questo vino
in minore ughi si è dove si pare utoe
per te questo anacoluto sughi carbonare
amatriciane norme divieti abbassare la
musica già mai avuto non ti ho mai
conosciuto ughi non vi abbiamo mai
conosciuti ughi abbassare la musica
giammai a testa alta ha avuto uv a testa
alta mai abbassare la musica
[Musica]